la suspension des fermetures de classes
en milieu rural n'aura duré qu'une
saison
la promesse faite par jean michel blanc
car l'année dernière de ne pas fermer de
classes à cause des conditions
sanitaires exceptionnelle ne semble plus
d'actualité
en tout cas pas du côté de preuilly sur
claise dans ce village de 1000 habitants
du sud touraine la future carte scolaire
prévoit la fermeture d'une classe
regroupant les enfants des communes
alentour samedi une centaine de parents
d'élèves et d'élus se sont mobilisés
devant l'établissement pour dire non à
cette fermeture
lucas chopin
[Musique]
la nouvelle est tombée comme un couperet
pour le regroupement pédagogique
intercommunal claeys et creuse
'l'annonce d'une fermeture de classe à
la rentrée prochaine dans une école qui
accueille les enfants de plusieurs
communes inquiète déjà les parents c'est
important parce que je trouve que nos
enfants ont le droit au même titre que
tout le monde d'avoir une une éducation
une équité sur le territoire une
éducation
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
et c'est vrai que dans nos campagnes on
voit quand même tous les services partir
les uns après les autres
c'est très dommage tout ça une
inquiétude partagée par la centaine de
manifestants samedi matin prouilly sur
claise les maires des communes
concernées eux craignent qu'à terme une
désertification des territoires ruraux
on se bat pour que nos montres notre
monde rural soit attractif qu'il soit le
plus accueillant possible pour que des
enfants s'épanouissent dans nos écoles
pour que la population avait vu une
école c'est le nerf de la guerre d'une
commune rurale et ce n'est pas en
agissant comme ça qu'on va faciliter le
fait de rendre encore plus attractive
notre monde rural des élus du conseil
départemental ont également fait le
déplacement pour demander à l'éducation
nationale de revenir sur sa décision
nous sommes dans des cantons défavorisés
déjà et je crois que si on veut garder
la population aujourd'hui il faut garder
les services qui existent et au niveau
du conseil départemental nous avons fait
justement entre le grand pressigny est
produit le réseau des collèges pour
maintenir toute cette population
ah je trouve que c'est dommage
aujourd'hui que l'éducation nationale
commencent à démonter ce qu'on aurait pu
faire nous en attendant un changement
élus et parents d'élèves ne lâcheront
rien d'autres manifestations devraient
être organisées prochainement